PROFESSOR: I now have that new
n of t that we wrote there.
I have to write
it as what it is.
It's i psi n of r of t times--
I will write it here
this way-- d dt--
the dot will be
replaced by the d dt--
psi n of r of t.
And then, of course,
the gamma n of t
will be just the
integral from 0 to t
of new n of t prime bt prime.
So that's the next step.
Well, if you have
to differentiate
a function that depends on
r of t, what do you have?
Let me do it for a simpler
case, d dt of f of r of t.
This means d dt of a
function of r1 of t
are all the ones up to rn of t.
And what must you do?
Well, you should do
df dr1 times dr1 dt
all the way up to
the df dr and drn dt.
You want to find the time
dependence of a function that
depends on a collection of
time-dependent coordinates.
Well, the chain rule applies.
But this can be written
in a funny language--
maybe not so funny--
as the gradient sub r vector
of f dotted dr vector dt.
See, the gradient, in
general, is d dx1 d dx2 d dx3.
It's a vector operator.
The gradient sub r would
mean d dr1 d dr2 d dr3,
just the gradient in
this Euclidean vector
space times dr dt.
So that's what I want to
use for this derivative.
I have to differentiate
that state.
And therefore, I'll
write it that way.
So gamma n of t is equal
to i, from the top line,
psi n of r of t times gradients
of r acting on the state psi
n of r of t dotted with dr dt.
This is dot product.
So just to make sure
you understand here,
you have one ket here, and
you have this gradient.
So that gives you
capital N components,
the derivative of the ket
with respect to r1 r2 r3 r4.
Then with the inner product,
it gives your capital
N numbers, which are the
components of a vector that is
being dotted with this vector.
It's all about
trying to figure out
that this language makes sense.
If this made sense to you,
this should make sense,
a little more, maybe a
tiny bit more confusing.
But maybe you should
write it all out.
What do you think it is?
And that might help you.
Or we could do that later.
So if we have that, we can go
to gamma n, the geometric phase.
So this is 0 2t, the integral
with respect to prime time,
so new m.
So it's i psi n r of t prime--
there's lots of vectors
here, gradient r vector
of psi n r of t prime
dotted dr dt prime dt prime.
That's the last dt prime.
And the good thing that
happened, the thing that
really makes all the
difference, the thing that
is responsible for
that conceptual thing
is just this cancellation.
This cancellation means that
you can think of the integral
as happening just in
the configuration space.
This is not really an
integral over time.
This is an integral
in configuration space
because now this integral is
nothing else than the integral
over the path gamma.
Because the path
gamma represents
the evolution of the coordinate
capital R from 0 to time t.
This is nothing else than
the integral over the path
gamma of i psi n of r--
I don't have to
write the t anymore--
dr psi n of r--
again no t-- dot dr. And this
is the geometric phase gamma n
that depends on r on the path.
I'll write it like that.
You see, something very
important has happened here.
It's a realization that
time plays no role anymore.
This is the concept.
This is what you have to
struggle to understand here.
This integral says
take this path.
Take a little dr dot it with
this gradient of this object,
which is kind of the gradient
of this ket, which is
a lot of kets with this thing.
So it's a vector.
Dot it with this and integrate.
And time plays no role.
You just follow the path.
So whether this
thing took one minute
to make the path
or a billion years,
the geometric phase will
be exactly the same.
It just depends on
the path it took.
Time for some names
for these things.
Let's see.
So a first name is
that this whole object
is going to be called
the Berry connection.
i psi n of r
gradient r psi n of r
is called the Berry
connection a n vector of r.
Berry connection.
OK, a few things to notice,
the Berry connection
is like a vector in the
configuration space.
It has capital N components
because this is a gradient.
And therefore, it produces
of this ket n kets
and, therefore, n numbers
because of the bra.
So this is a thing with
capital N components.
So it's a vector in RN.
But people like the
name connection.
Why Connection?
Because it's a little
more subtle than a vector.
It transforms under
Gage transformation,
your favorite things.
And it makes it interesting
because it transforms
under Gage transformation.
We'll see it in a second.
So it's a connection
because of that.
And there's one Berry
connection for every eigenstate
of your system.
Because we fix some n,
and we got the connection.
And we're going to get different
connections for different n's.
So n components,
one per eigenstate,
and they live all over
the configuration space.
You can ask, what is
the value of the Berry
connection at this point?
And there is an answer.
At every point, this
connection exists.
Now, let's figure out the issue
of gauge transformations here.
And it's important because
this subject somehow--
these formulas, I
think in many ways,
were known to everybody
for a long time.
But Berry probably clarified
this issue of the time
independence and
emphasized that this could
be interesting in some cases.
But in fact, in most
cases, you could say
they're not all that relevant.
You can change them.
So here is one thing
that can happen.
You have your
energy eigenstates,
your instantaneous eigenstates.
You solve them,
and you box them.
You're very happy with them.
But in fact, they're
far from unique.
Your energy eigenstates,
your instantaneous energy
eigenstates can be changed.
If you have an energy
eigenstate psi n of r--
that's what it is--
well, you could decide
to find another one.
Psi prime of r is going to
be equal to e to the minus
some function, arbitrary
function, of r times this.
And these new states
are energy eigenstates,
instantaneous energy
eigenstates that
are as good as
your original psi n
because this equation also
holds for the psi n primes.
If you add with the Hamiltonian,
the Hamiltonian in here
just goes through this and
hits here, produces the energy,
and then the state
is just the same.
The r of t's are parameters
of the Hamiltonian.
They're not operators.
So there's no reason
why the Hamiltonian
would care about this factor.
The r's are just parameters.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: No, they're
still normalized.
I should put a phase here--
thank you very much--
minus i.
Thank you.
Yes, I want the states
to be normalized,
and I want them
to be orthonormal.
And all that is not changed
if I put them phase.
So this is the funny thing
about quantum mechanics.
It's all about phases
and complex numbers.
But you can, to a large degree,
change those phases at will.
And whatever survives is some
sort of very subtle effects
between the phases.
So here I put the i
and beta of r is real.
PROFESSOR: So you can say
let's compute the new Berry
connection associated with
this new state a n prime of r.
So I must do that operation
that we have up there
with the news state.
So I would have i psi n of r
times e to the i beta of r.
That's The bra.
Then I have dr and now the
ket, e to the minus i beta of r
psi n of r.
So this is, by definition,
the new Berry connection
associated to your new,
redefined eigenstates.
Now this nabla is acting
on everything to the right.
Suppose it acts on the state
and then the two exponentials
will cancel, and then you
get the old connection.
So there is one term here,
which is just the old a n of r.
There's all these arrows there.
There's probably five arrows
at least I miss on every board.
Here is a 1, 2, 3, 4 5.
OK, so this is the
first one, and then you
have the term for this gradient
acts on this exponential.
When the gradient acts
on the exponential,
it gives the same
exponential times
the gradient of the exponent.
The exponentials then cancel.
The gradient of the exponent
would give me plus i times
minus i gradient of beta.
Maybe I'll put the r of the r.
And then these cancel, and you
have the state with itself,
which gives you 1.
So that's all it is, all that
the second term gives you.
So here we get a n of r plus
gradient r of beta of r.
So this is the gauge
transformation.
And you say, wow,
I can see now why
this is called a connection.
Because just like
the vector potential
under a gauge
transformation, it transforms
with a gradient of a function.
So it really transforms
as a vector potential, all
in this space called
the configuration space,
not in real space.
In the configuration space it
acts like a vector potential.
And that's why it's
called a connection.
But let's see.
We have now what happens
to the connection.
Let's see what happens to the
Berry's phase if you do this.
So the Berry's phase over
there is this integral.
So the Berry's phase can change.
And let's see what happens
to the Berry's phase.
So what is the geometric
phase gamma n of gamma?
In plain language, it is
the integral over gamma--
from here, I'm just
copying the formula--
of a n of r, the Berry
connection, times dr.
So what is the new Berry phase
for your new instantaneous
energy eigenstates?
Now you would say,
if the Berry phase
is something that is
observable, it better not
depend just on your
convention to choose
the instantaneous
energy eigenstates.
And this is just
your convention.
Because if a problem
is sufficiently messy,
I bet you guys would all
come up with different energy
eigenstates because the phases
are chosen in different ways.
So it better not change
if the Berry phase
is to be significant.
So what is the prime thing?
Well, we still integrate
over the same path, but now
the prime connection--
but that is the old
connection a n of rd r,
the old Berry's phase, plus
the integral over gamma,
or I will write it from
initial the final r.
Maybe I should have ir
and i f in the picture.
If you want to, you can put
this r of time equals 0 as ri
and r of time equal tf
is rf the extra term,
the gradient of beta dot dr.
So this is the old Berry phase.
So the new Berry phase
is the old Berry phase.
And how about the last integral?
Does it vanish?
No, it doesn't vanish.
It gifts you.
But in fact, it can be done.
This is like derivative
times this thing,
so it's one of those
simple integrals.
The gradient times the
d represents the change
in the function as
you move a little dr.
So when you go from ri to rf,
the integral of the gradient
is equal to the
function beta at rf
minus the function beta on ri.
This is like when you
integrate the electric field
along a line, and
the electric field
is the gradient
of the potential.
The integral of the electric
field through a line
is the potential here
minus the potential there.
So here this is plus beta
or rf minus beta of ri.
So it's not gauge invariant
in the Berry phase.
And therefore, it will mean that
most of the times it cannot be
observed.
It's not gauge invariant.
Whatever is not gauge
invariant cannot be observed.
You cannot say you make a
measurement and the answer is
gauge-dependent because
everybody is going to get
a different answer.
And whose answer is right?
That's not possible.
So if this Barry phase seems to
have failed a very basic thing,
then it's not gauge-invariant.
But there is one way in
which this gets fixed.
If your motion in the
configuration space
begins and ends in the same
place, these two will cancel.
And then it will
be gauge-invariant.
So the observable Berry's
phase is a geometric phase
accumulated by the system in a
motion in a configuration space
where it begins and
ends in the same point.
Otherwise, it's not observable.
You can eliminate it.
And so this is an
important result
that the geometric Berry
phase for a closed path
in the configuration
space is gauge-invariant.